Oh
[Music]
Oh
hey everybody welcome back to our city
today I'll be continuing the expansion
of the city in the sub urban area which
I started working on in the last episode
so in that sense it's going to be a bit
of splendid furnishings we're really
just getting more suburbs in but I'll
also be focusing on a large mosque in
the center of it and some of the decal
assets which have come out of the course
of the past couple of weeks which might
add some extra detail and unique touches
to the city without having to really get
rid of that clean look so without
further ado let's get into the
time-lapse and let's get into me
building the mosque right away because I
really figured that was the most
important thing for me to do at this
point I've gotten quite a few comments
about the lack of mosques in the city
which is actually really good because I
needed that stuff pretty honestly there
was an incredible lack of mosques in the
city so far I had plans to have at least
five most in the city but even that is a
very small number considering the
population of the city so that's
something I definitely might want to
re-evaluate as well but the fact that we
need more mosques in here is pretty much
for certain given that this is
supposedly in Bahrain so I figured this
would be the best place again a new
mosque in and this is someone recently
posted a set I'm not sure anymore how I
found it but it actually works really
well it does have the general Arab style
to it in terms of architecture and there
is barely anything like that on the
workshop there is the Dubai assets which
I'll definitely talk a little bit more
about at some point later in this video
but there is barely any efforts that
really fit the style of this city and
this building in particular I feel could
work as a large mosque especially as
that sort of community center that
that's the function that I kind of
wanted the building to have it's a bit
similar to what I had in the
neighborhood earlier on where I built
the first mosque of the city there's
that small sort of central area
that part of the city where there is a
train station connected to some shopping
streets connected to a Bulevar as well
as some of the basic services like the
police station and as well of course
the mosque so you kind of have that
community center in the middle of one of
them the outskirts of the city if you
remember in one of the earlier episodes
might even have been episode one then I
talked about the the sort of multiple
hub approach for the city where there's
one big city center or downtown if you
will but every part of the city has its
own hubs for for that community to do
things that you might otherwise have to
go through to the downtown for and this
is sort of part of that approach and I
really felt that this was the best
building to fit that in also because it
fits perfectly at the end of that road
which is again kind of like the first
mosque it has the train station it has
some of the more important buildings
around this suburb the general shopping
area as well there's that waterfront
with the look of the downtown so it's
really the most important street of this
of this this residential area here if
you will so I figured this was the best
place to have that mosque and also back
it up a little bit by than awkward water
which is currently sitting empty at the
end of the mosque where we're going to
have a marina in due time so that we
also kind of fulfill that function now I
guess no this is an all residential the
idea behind the entire city is that it's
mixed views but this is more or less be
more suburban area but I'll probably
talk a little bit more about that later
on as well because in the end and this
is something that I also wanted to
mention I know that a lot of these
videos are very similar and I'm really
sorry about that there isn't really too
much that I can do about it i streamed
some of it and I've done some work
off-camera but there is just so much
work to get the body of the city in
before I can move to more unique
interesting things like the airports or
power plants that there really is it's
so much work that I have to make these
episodes out of them and there is a fair
amount of
and much like the episodes before this
one where I did be similar sort of
outskirt areas of the city I kinda just
want to talk about City skylines in
general maybe one of them watching and
the ideas that are behind the city and
you know especially because in two weeks
since I uploaded the last episode and
since there's been all sorts of amazing
stuff going on in the city skylines
community I think there's lots of things
to talk about
even in relation to the city which I'm
building here so in the meantime before
I go off from that trail I'm just
working on the the general suburb areas
over here this is the only parts of the
city or of this area which I'm building
in this episode which is somewhat them
since this is still someone close to to
the core of this neighborhood but the
rest will also be quite focused on
making these row houses and more suburb
asked buildings and getting some of the
details in like all the parts all of the
all of the the decals and the foliage
work now what I really wanted to talk
about is the latest episode of Utah's
yesteryear series which is a series that
you might know it's been existing for
longer than this one has though the the
uploads or somewhat infrequent I know
some people like to joke about like
they're never being any episodes and the
upload schedule being very very rare but
there's there's some really amazing
episodes in there and it was actually
one of the series that inspired me also
to build a city not focused on detail or
how good it looks in game per se but
more on the philosophy and ideas behind
it it's what if you definitely have to
watch it if you're into that kind of
stuff but it's generally it's it's in
the future and it has all sorts of urban
planning but even beyond that it has
also to futurology sort of aspect behind
it and it's really interesting series to
follow in his latest episode he actually
has Jeff spank who is from what I
remember an urbanist city planner who's
actually has set Fulks before which
really good as well
and he actually did an interview with
him on that video now I don't want to
talk like about those exact topics you
should check out the video if you're
interested in it it's really good but
what I found most interesting is that it
definitely quite relates to the city
what Jeff speck talks about a lot is the
yani of walkability and cream cheese
that are walkable for many of the
reasons that I guess I've already talked
about a little bit in some of the
earlier episodes and I definitely
recognize you know myself kind of being
in that filter bubble of of like city
Lamport costs strong towns 99 percent is
for maybe relish groups that was my mp3
player maybe maybe read it
urban planning those kinds of places
were like Pro pedestrian views and anti
car Jews run very rampant for very good
reasons but anyway he talks about these
ideas and one thing that struck me most
and that I found very interesting with
me being Dutch and making this city was
the idea of making streets walkable by
making them more interesting and this is
super common sense in a way and I am not
sure how I completely forgot about this
but the idea is really that you want to
have interesting buildings changing
environments to make it interesting for
people to walk you don't want to walk
through a neighborhood where you're just
walking past a huge parking garages each
end or just through a slat wall for an
extended period of time and I thought it
was kind of an interesting way for me to
relate to the issue of making some of
the more suburb areas in our city more
walkable and what it especially made me
think of was the Dutch superb than I
live in myself and when you hear the
word suburb you might already start
cringing and be like no that's not
walkable no way but I feel for the place
that I live which is quite definitely a
suburb it's actually a very walkable
place I don't even have a driver's
license and I walk quite a bit around
the area and I know that actually quite
some people do whenever I go to
so it's recently or go to get groceries
or anything I pretty much just walk it
it's a walkable suburb and what I never
really realized much up to this point I
guess is that part of that might not
just lie in fact that there are barely
any cars around insects I'd have to
watch out more recyclers than cars or
the fact that just walking cycling
taking urban transit is much less
relatively sponsored in the Netherlands
or any larger issues but that part of
the issue of making an area walkable is
just making it look varied like having
all kinds of different buildings making
it interesting to walk in and I'm sure
you've heard of some of the experiments
of people that have found that people
are willing to walk or drive or cycle a
longer route if that route is more
interesting if there are more
interesting buildings along the way
things like that and for me that was
something interesting to get more into
the suburbs of the city of MIT in
particular and try to make these areas
walkable despite them being much less
dense and know they're still being on
our city by at least varying the amount
of different houses that I use and using
all kinds of different houses within one
street and especially getting all of
that foliage in and colorful pathways
and everything in such a way that the
city perhaps doesn't even have to look
beautiful from an in-game standpoint but
if it were in real life it would at
least be much more fun to walk through
than any kind of simple hole head say
just American typical suburb with every
house being a carbon copy of the one
next to it
and that that was something that's
always very interesting the video in
general is very interesting but it's
something that really relates to the way
that I'm hoping to make on my 50 year
anyway just to catch up for a little bit
I also went into some decals over here
and decals and extra details quite a bit
of the downtown area some of these parts
were still very empty and many of them
also really liked some detail to it
so I decided I wanted to get back to
that at least a little bit and add some
of these these
new very large decals to add some
texture to the Ethel and to the concrete
and also get some extra planters and
stuff in so overall it should hopefully
look a little bit better I'm not sure
how much more I can really do with the
decals they're not really meant for the
kind of textures that I'm using on my
map unfortunately and for some of them
they really clash like I don't really
have too much to really make use of it
all so I didn't want to overuse some of
those decals because that might look
like
everything is very old and kind of
dilapidated when you know that can look
really beautiful in game but it's not
the kind of look that I'm trying to go
for it here but anyway I thought that
could add a slightly more unique touch
to the city but now we're back to
suburbs anyway now what I also kind of
wanted to talk about on the topic of
detailing is this city isn't really
focused on detail it's really just about
the ideas behind the city and the making
of this fantasy city of mine into
somewhat reality but recently there's
been some really like amazing astounding
detailing on city skylines there have
long been like really great detailed
projects in city skylines but just more
or less restricted to some topless or
this subreddits in pictures but recently
I've also began following like some
youtubers who just popped on the scene
and like are doing more and more
detailed work and it's so incredible
that I kind of just wanted to give a
shout out one of them being creative Dex
who has some really amazing stuff out
there you might know him for lindbloom
which hit the Steam Workshop scope which
is really awesome but he's got so much
amazing detailed stuff and another one
being Chrome's McGee who is like really
focused recently on making smaller
intersections and smaller projects with
an amazing amount of detail and like
using all of the new decals and foliage
to the fullest and it looks really
amazing that's some kind of stuff that I
would love to get into someday but I
guess I can only wish I can actually
make stuff that looks that good and part
of me is also just like Armour City has
lately different focus but it's it's
great stuff in the game nonetheless and
also what I really wanted to mention as
well is that there's a new series by I
keep forgetting how to pronounce his
name even though a toy is in the video
description anyway if I remember
correctly it spelled IH x no way IH xai
yeah that's it oh it's just X I I guess
which has a new series in which is
retraining to by a in a collab with
asset creators and it is already looking
really amazing and when it comes to like
recreating something to some of the
smallest details and creating also just
beautiful boat layouts it's already one
of my favorite series ever even though
there's only one episode of it I'm not
sure why I'm trying to just get everyone
shout outs in this video but it's
something that I thought was really
amazing and if you're interested in
homeland city you might be interested in
that kind of stuff as well even though
omar city is trying to go against the
dubai sort of city building in city
skylines i think in the end it can still
be something that's super interesting to
watch and can be done really beautifully
as well yeah that was basically I guess
my weekly fix when it comes to my
favorite stuff in cities counts of
course there's always you know the good
stuff that probably everybody knows at
this point my extra coaster influx but I
just wanted to talk about this stuff
because it's it's stuff that you know
keeps me busy as well and I definitely
like to watch other series as well and
if you if you haven't heard of any of
this stuff because there are some
smaller youtubers who don't guess get as
much attention and you're still
interested to check out some more series
you definitely check it out because it's
really amazing stuff anyway that is all
I wanted to really say about that I'm
trying to finish up this part of the
city at this point and I think it's also
a good time to start talking a little
bit about my future plans even though
those still quite vague I know I named
drops the airports
in this episode I am sort of in the
preparation of making Airport that said
I'm sort of in preparation for all kinds
of stuff I actually spent two hours
before this episode just trying to mess
with the road textures and see if I
could get any good ones with roads
United but none of them like had non
colored bus roads so they all turn the
bus roads into blank asphalt and I was
not having any of that so we're just
back to normal now but anyway I also
like got into some mobs for airports and
finally decided to update my list for
airport assets and that Jen's as well so
hopefully we should be getting into
airports as soon as possible when I
actually have the layouts and have some
tests with the airport and know what I'm
going for and also there are of course
some plans to get into University some
sporting facilities as well a hospital
of some kind a large park although that
will be outside of the city permaculture
is definitely something that I would
like to try as well and of course there
is the issue of energy not sure if I
ever talked about this before but the
plan is just to have fields of solar
panels outside the city that is my
current plan I may very well change my
mind and I'm open for any suggestions as
always of course but these are some of
the things that I want to head into once
actually have most of the buildings done
and to be quite frank even if I don't
have the entire sort of body parts of
the city done I wanted to move into this
area right here because this is where
the airport is going to be and you might
notice that very straight section of
send sort of jutting out into the sea
that is the area where I am planning to
have the airport at some point in the
future so we'll definitely see that
expansion happening at some point very
soon along the road as well for now
though it's just all about finishing
needs of urban areas and another final
thing that I had to do in this episode
which is coming up in a little bit is to
actually get in the marina which is
again quite simple and it's quite small
as well I'm still not sure how exactly
I'm going to regulate the entry into the
sea because quite obviously I can't just
have it
just like that so whether I'll have to
have a barrier around the entire city or
something similar we'll see at some
point in the future but this is the
simple marina for now with just some
boats and a way to bring the entire area
to life a little bit more and with that
I would like to conclude this episode
thank you guys for watching I'm sorry if
it was again a little bit more messy
trying to get back into the real content
sometime soon with some of the more
exciting stuffs and more unique stuff
that will be happening in the city
we're almost done with some of the basic
necessary stuff just hang on for a
little bit more and I'll see you in some
of the future episodes bye guys
[Music]